okay let's get straight into discussing
the climate issues of the day tonight
with lecturer in international relations
at cardiff university jen allen and
extinction rebellion activist and
co-founder of the cop 26 climate action
plan chidi oti obihara there they both
are and we're going to discuss the
cancellation of part of the high-speed
rail network today it's provoked strong
reaction hasn't it among those who were
looking forward to faster transport
links and an efficient public transport
system is crucial of course if the uk is
to reach its emissions targets well
let's get the reaction of jen
first of all um the hs2 eastern leg
being scrapped it really is a blow isn't
it to achieving a low carbon very
efficient public transport network
well it depends on what happens next
because right now it's tough to see how
the actions of the government actually
will get us to net zero there's only
about two billion for walking and
cycling
7 for public transport
and so with this cancellation
maybe existing lines could be upgraded
in a way to get people where they need
to be faster and more reliably
but if that doesn't happen then yeah
it's not going to help us hit net zero
in any way
yeah and that's exactly what the
government's argument is isn't it chidi
that actually what they can do is
upgrade spend a bit more money on the
existing line rather than throwing
billions at hs2
what do you think you're absolutely
right the reversal of the beaching cuts
is part of the process we're going
through right now but i think the
challenge of trying to understand what's
going on with hs2 is that we're treating
transport to the north of england that's
a problem that has to be solved rather
than looking at the opportunities that
are there that we can expand on
so the cancellation that we've seen has
to have a review of what the actual
costs and benefits are we don't know
what the biodiversity costs to that leg
were we don't know how this changes that
equation the whole hs2 project runs on
the supposition that it's uh it reduces
the cost of carbon travel to eight grams
per person per mile
now it's eight times that if you go by
car and it's about 20 times that if you
fly
so hs2 does have benefits that it
provides whether or not this rule change
is a net cost or a net benefit is
something we don't yet know
of course jen the other argument is that
if you're going to build new railway
lines that causes a huge amount of
damage to the environment and to the
countryside
yeah and there are a few things that are
a bit strange with some of the hs2
builds that was happening like digging
up an entire ecosystem and saying we can
replant it and it'll be fine we can
transplant an entire ancient woodland
which doesn't have a lot of success
stories out there
so you know
as we were saying there's a lot of
uncertainties here so now we're dealing
with things that we know we know what
the existing links are we know how they
have to be approved but that can't
really be well planned from london
so
putting money into councils into
communities
they know who needs to get where
where people work where people live and
where people play
they're the ones best place to figure
out efficient transit